لقد تعاملنا بالشفافية مع العالم ، حيث
شاركنا الأدلة التي رفعت عنها السرية حول
خطط روسيا وهجماتها الإلكترونية
وذرائعها الكاذبة حتى لا يكون هناك أي
لبس أو تستر حول ما
كان
بوتين يفعله بوتين هو أن المعتدي
بوتين اختار هذه
الحرب والآن هو  وستتحمل بلاده
العواقب
اليوم ، فأنا أصرح بفرض عقوبات قوية إضافية
وقيود جديدة على ما يمكن
تصديره إلى روسيا ،
وهذا سيفرض تكلفة باهظة على
الاقتصاد الروسي على الفور ومع
مرور الوقت ،
وقد صممنا هذه
العقوبات بشكل هادف لتعظيم  تأثير طويل المدى
على روسيا ولتقليل
التأثير على الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائنا وأريد أن أوضح
أن الولايات المتحدة لا تفعل ذلك
بمفردها
منذ شهور ، لقد قمنا ببناء
تحالف من الشركاء يمثلون
أكثر من نصف العالم.  الاقتصاد
27 عضوًا في الاتحاد الأوروبي
بما في ذلك فرنسا وألمانيا وإيطاليا
وكذلك المملكة المتحدة وكندا واليابان
وأستراليا ونيوزيلندا والعديد من الدول الأخرى
تضخيم التأثير المشترك لاستجابتنا ،
لقد تحدثت للتو مع قادة مجموعة السبع هذا
الصباح ونحن في اتفاق كامل وكامل
سنحد من قدرة روسيا على القيام
بأعمال تجارية بالدولار والجنيه الإسترليني والين
لتكون جزءًا من الاقتصاد العالمي
سيحد من قدرتها  للقيام بذلك ،
سنقوم بإعاقة القدرة على
التمويل وزيادة الاندفاع للجيش الروسي ،
فإن قواتنا
ليست ولن تشارك في الصراع
مع روسيا في أوكرانيا ،
فإن قواتنا لن تذهب إلى أوروبا
للقتال في أوكرانيا ولكن للدفاع
حلفاءنا في الناتو وطمئن هؤلاء الحلفاء في
الشرق
كما أوضحت تمامًا
أن الولايات المتحدة ستدافع عن كل شبر
من أراضي الناتو بالقوة الكاملة للقوة
الأمريكية والخبر السار هو أن
الناتو كان أكثر اتحادًا وأكثر إصرارًا
من أي وقت مضى
بين أفعالنا و  تلك الخاصة
بحلفائنا وشركائنا ، نقدر
أننا سنقطع أكثر من نصف واردات روسيا
عالية التقنية
، وستوجه ضربة لقدرتهم على
الاستمرار في تحديث
جيشهم.  تحطيم صناعة الطيران الخاصة بهم
بما في ذلك برنامجهم الفضائي
، سيضر بقدرتهم على بناء السفن
مما يقلل من قدرتها على المنافسة
اقتصاديًا وستكون ضربة كبيرة
لطموحات بوتين الإستراتيجية طويلة الأجل
، مما يخون الرؤية الشريرة
لمستقبل عالمنا
واحدًا أكثر  تأخذ الدول ما تريد
بالقوة ،
لكنها رؤية ستعارضها الولايات المتحدة
والدول المحبة للحرية في
كل مكان بكل أداة
من قوتنا الكبيرة
، ستندمج الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤنا
وشركاؤنا من هذا أقوى
وأكثر اتحادًا وأكثر تصميمًا وأكثر
إن عدوان بوتين المتعمد ضد أوكرانيا
سينتهي به الأمر إلى تكبد روسيا غالياً
اقتصادياً واستراتيجياً ،
وسوف نتأكد من أن
بوتين سيكون منبوذاً على
المسرح الدولي
لأي محاسب أمة ، حيث أن عدوان روسيا العاري
ضد أوكرانيا سوف يكون
ملطخاً بالاقتران
مع تاريخ هذه الحقبة.
اختيار بوتين المكتوب
لشن حرب غير مبررة على
أوكرانيا على إرادة  لقد تركوا روسيا أضعف
وبقية العالم أقوى ،
والديمقراطية والحرية والكرامة الإنسانية ، فهذه
هي القوى أقوى بكثير من
الخوف والقمع
التي لا يمكن القضاء عليها من قبل الطغاة
مثل بوتين وجيوشه
ولا يمكن محوها من قبل الناس من
قلوب الناس
وآمالهم.  كمية العنف والترهيب
التي يتعرضون لها
في الصراع بين الديمقراطية والاستبداد
بين السيادة والقهر
لا يخطئون في
أن تسود الحرية